lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
practicar la resolución de exponentes en
decimales digamos que tengo 0.2 a la
tercera potencia pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo
bueno esto significa que si tengo algo a
la tercera potencia multiplico es el
número tres veces así que tengo 0.2 por
0.2 por 0.2 cuál va a ser el resultado
de esto si multiplico 0.2 por 0.2
el resultado es 0.04 una manera de
pensar en esto es decir 2 por 2 es igual
a 4 después tengo un número a la derecha
del punto decimal y tengo otro dígito a
la derecha del punto decimal por lo que
mi producto va a tener dos dígitos a la
derecha del punto decimal así que el
resultado es 0.04 y luego si multiplico
eso por 0.2 cuál va a ser el resultado
bueno 4 por 2 es igual a 8 y ahora tengo
123 números a la derecha del punto
decimal así que mi producto va a tener
decimal
ahora que tenemos un poco de práctica
con esto hagamos otro ejemplo digamos
que quiero saber cuánto es 0.9 al
cuadrado pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo muy bien esto es igual a 0.9
por 0.9 cuál es el resultado de esto
bueno podemos decir que el 9 por 9 es
igual a 81 y en los dos números que
estoy multiplicando tengo un total de 1
y 2 dígitos a la derecha del punto
decimal así que mi respuesta tendrá 12
dígitos a la derecha del punto decimal
por lo tanto pongo mi punto decimal aquí
y pongo el 0 de modo que tengo 0.81 otra
manera de pensar en esto es decir 9
décimos de 9 décimos es igual a 81
centésimos usar exponentes o elevar
decimales algún exponente es lo mismo
que hacerlo con números enteros sólo que
en este caso tenemos que hacer un poco
de multiplicaciones con decimales
hemos terminado